voyez près ces élèves du secondaire
participent au projet écolo chain dans
une région agricole où la relève est
difficile à trouver
manon dolbec et son conjoint donne un
coup de pouce sont en voie d'être à la
retraite
donc ils nous ont prêté une parcelle de
terre les jeunes y ont planté mille
melon d'eau qu'à une variété de
cantaloup qui n'a pas été cultivées
depuis les années 50 on a commencé par
planter les amants transmis à
l'intérieur après on a fait le travail
celle de planck est en fait le sarclage
dans les rues aujourd'hui montviel et
cueillir qui on espère enfin coutin pas
l'école pourrait vraiment mon triste
on est vraiment dans le terroir
présentement le est du melon d'eau cas
donc elle est libre et des libres et du
melon et banana et dieu et du melon de
montréal les frères trappistes cia ou
encore qu'ils ont entrepris à partir de
1912 jusqu'à 1924 la création d'un
nouveau melon qui permettrait à
l'ensemble des agriculteurs du québec de
le cultiver à partir du climat québécois
bien entendu le melon d'eau qu'à
disparaît dans les années 50 au profit
d'autres variétés avant que jean
françois lévesque leurs traces dans une
banque de semences d'une fondation
américaine
ce retour au bercail intéresse aussi les
chefs antonin michaud et benjamin
langlais à la fois sucré mais pas trop
de vraiment un goût prononcé de
cucurbitacées donc c'est très
intéressant pour nous de pouvoir jouer
un peu sur ce goulot s'apprêterait
sorbet ça peut être un jeu qui ça peut
être une tata carlos travail et du melon
en plus c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
tendance à faire pour nous après un défi
c'est très intéressant d'apprendre
l'histoire le donc du mal aussi bien la
région je m'envoie l'abbaye l'abandon du
maillot qui a été développée d'abord qui
revient sur les terres dans le c'est à
nous de mettre en cause la valeur pour
le moment les chefs ont 150 melon à
mettre en valeur avant de les faire
découvrir à leurs tirs ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada au cas